are the aliens real or not tell me bro i
don't know you know the first time we
ever hung out we went out today i don't
think anybody knows about this they
might not you tell me hey what are you
doing for dinner tonight and we go with
bob lazar allegedly according to him he
back engineered alien spacecrafts so
we're certain they are eating and bob
lazar is detailing to us [ __ ] that he
couldn't even talk about on the podcast
wild here's the work it's wild wanna
hear the whole story he had top secret
clearance because of that they had to
tap into his phone during that time
period his wife is having an affair they
kill his top secret clearance and
suspend him so they don't tell him
though they don't tell him his wife is
cheating on him so he's trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] is going on and he
brings friends out into the mountains to
view the launches of these ufos and he
was watching with his friends these
[ __ ] things flying around in like
these preposterous ways that no airplane
could fly i want to state for the record
that most this podcast is nonsense we
like to be safe and just go 100 100 it's
all comedy if asked i stand by none of
my claims